three let's see if this works
give a couple of seconds for people to
percolate
on and in and then we should be good to
go
let's see here did anybody
join yet we don't have any joiners on
yet but that's okay because i've got a
ton of questions
for my guest professor jen 11 how are
you today
congratulations on another phenomenal
book launch of this wonderful book black
hole survival guide congratulations
jenna
thank you so much it's always exciting
when a book comes out it's hard to
believe it's finished you you always
feel like you're never going to finish a
book
right it's just this and then and then
all of a sudden it's done
the build up the letdown and then the
hmm should i start writing another book
when should i start writing another book
well congratulations we've got a bunch
of people watching live
on youtube currently and my name is
brian keating host
of the into the impossible podcast and
uh it's not too often you get to hear me
you know
gushing like a white hole when i get a
guest
the caliber of today's john 11 and not
only once are we going to be blessed to
have janna on the into the impossible
podcast but twice in a day
because janna has graciously agreed to
come back on tonight
for the great debate live stream second
millennium
uh janna thank you so much where are you
today are you in new york city
i'm in new york city and as you can see
i'm being my own tech person as i make
slight adjustments
it's so glamorous the life of an author
to be a tech person
in new york city yeah oh it's great and
so
so campus is closed but you're teaching
remotely as you're launching a book as
you're raising a family
how do you find time to do it all i
don't i definitely don't the days are a
blur
the days are a blur yeah and even i
wouldn't have it any other way though
yeah that's right it keeps things
exciting actually i want to start with
there yeah
so i was uh your team was gracious
enough to get me a copy of the
e-book so i read the book basically in a
couple of hours
it's such a such a treat it's a slim
volume
but it has the information density of of
a black hole it is so
full and you know
i i always said when you know i actually
had you know you were part of my live
stream on friday with uh sir roger
penrose
and i always love it when somebody says
you know i learned something from your
book and
and usually it's like you know it's kind
of a little bit condescending so i don't
want it to sound that way
but when he said that to me i felt
really good about my book but i want to
say that about your but i learned a
tremendous amount and it raised so many
questions
and uh and the thing that i first want
to point out is that it's a work of art
too
so you are the director of the pioneer
works tell us what is pioneer works did
it inspire this book
um uh in your mind this blend melange
between
science and art yeah yeah pioneer
works is a new cultural center it's only
a few years old
it's in red hook brooklyn which is right
on the water in brooklyn
it's a beautiful old ironworks factory
that was converted
into a space for art and music and tech
and now science because i'm the director
of sciences there we brought science to
pioneer works and i very much believe
science just
is part of culture and we had this
immediate synergy
with the founders and um it's
it's really a place for experimentation
and exploration where science and art
rub together we don't use this trite
thing where we force scientists and
artists necessarily to specifically
collaborate
it's really just that they get to rub
shoulders
and exciting wonderful things happen so
sometimes we do talks i did a
talk with peter gallison a couple of
years ago about his film containment on
nuclear
waste and you know real high level
science talk but we did it in the midst
of the hiroshima panels
which was a stunning exhibit
of these panels that were painted by
these japanese artists who were in
hiroshima
within days after um after the bomb so
you have this rubbing
of of these deep cultural um ideas and
concepts and perspectives
leah halloran who's the artist for the
book i'm glad you started with that is a
very dear friend of mine
and i was very near the end of the book
actually
and i finally saw what the book was and
i know you you understand this feeling
sometimes you set out to
have a scientific theory or write a book
and you go the opposite direction you go
a different direction because it guides
you you discover things on
on the journey and one of the things i
realized was i wanted this book to be
beautiful
in the language and physically and so i
reached out to leah and asked her if she
would do
uh paintings instead of having graphic
figures
and so leah painted 20 over 20 original
paintings for the book so it really is
beautiful i'm going to show you i'm
going to show you because i
i know you have it up there but look how
tiny it is it's so cute
and then these pictures these pictures
are just you know that that leah did are
just
are just so gorgeous you know she did
these like wonderful paintings for it
and she even did the author image so my
author image is even a painting
oh wow i didn't know she did that no
that's phenomenal yeah
so it made the book so special for me
to be a collaboration with an artist um
and did it grow specifically out of
pioneer works in some ways but in some
ways pioneer works science department
grew out of that
that desire and leo was in fact uh
through our friendship of resident in
the science studios
for a little while where she would come
and paint in the science studios while
we were
while we were doing our thing and um
it's just the way i've always wanted to
live
you know that's what i said it's the
world i've always wanted to live in so
we're kind of building it from scratch
yeah and i wanted to uh just read the
the introduction or the
um the afterward which really has a
tribute to her we'll read your
uh intro in a second but leah halloran
is an artist who often draws from
concepts in the history of astronomy
she developed her love of science
beginning with her first job at the age
of 15
in san francisco dissecting cow eyes so
you know that's
if you're not worried about survival i
guess you won't be um you know nauseated
by
cowa she's a painter and a photographer
living in los angeles represented in los
angeles by luis de jesus los angeles
and uh and she's also an associate
professor of art at chapman university
we've had on
michael shermer who's a professor there
of um yeah
it's in the sciences he runs the science
along
um and skeptic magazine but i want to
talk about a commonality i
interviewed i don't know if you've ever
met him seth godin do you know who that
is
i know the name but i don't think we've
met he's like he invented email
marketing
he's famous for losing six billion
dollars uh he claims
because he didn't monetize this idea to
spam people
he's a phenomenal mind he runs this alt
mba program it has a nice podcast called
the into the i was going to say the into
the impossible podcast although that
reminds me
those of you who don't get enough
exercise in this time of pandemic just
exercise your finger
and click subscribe on my youtube
channel and thumbs up because tonight
janna is going to be back you don't want
to miss that uh but i talked to seth
godin last week on my channel and he
uh he said that great artists uh thrive
on constraints
your book seemed to me wow to be this
paragon of constraints he says that
creative people don't
ship their work because they're too
afraid and they're too
unbounded it seems to me you're known
for
thinking about constraints and the power
that constraints have your previous book
which we discussed this past summer uh
black hole blues which is another
just delightful book uh was about the
power of constraint on an experimental
team searching for the ultimate signal
of black holes
your book prior to that was the madman
dreams of turing machines
about two diametrically opposed in some
sense
uh brilliant minds uh plagued by
constraints in their field
girdle with the complete incompleteness
of mathematics
and um and touring with the you know
possibility of constraints on the power
of computers
uh what is it about constraints that
allows your mind to thrive and and how
do you handle all the constraints that
you have
and produce some so much great creative
content
brian it's a truly excellent question
when i was a postdoc
at berkeley at the center for particle
astrophysics um
so young postdoc still figuring it out
uh i shared an office with uh who is now
professor pedro ferreira at oxford
but at the time he like me was a young
postdoc still figuring it out
and we're in such a small office that
our chairs would
knock together the backs of our chairs
and so sometimes to talk to each other
we would simply lean back jen would be
able to be face to face
and he said to me one day he said i'm
obsessed with constrained creativity
and ever since he said that it was like
it was like an epiphany i i had been
struggling with the same concepts but i
hadn't
found the right way of saying it and
there is this
magic when imagination crashes into
constraints
i i really believe that the best artists
have
incredibly severe constraints that they
self-impose
and only then can they within that
very firm and structurally sound
scaffolding
can they be genuinely creative one of
the examples i love is james tyrell
the famous artist who just uses light
and to the point that i mean he really
just
uses light there is no focal point there
is no
object there is to some sense no lens
he simply relates to light and it is
just
phenomenal work um some of the some of
the great work
of of contemporary art and so i believe
that that's true obviously with science
when
when i was a kid i thought scientists
just memorized and recited things a
terrible
terrible stereotype that i don't even
know where it came from but as i
discovered it
in college really i i realized oh wow
what you can do if you tighten your
constraints is unbelievable and in fact
in the beginning of the book i talk
about how the most
rigid limits created revolutions
it was though when you squeeze down in
one direction
you explode in the other and relativity
which is really the basis of this whole
book is one of those examples einstein
could have called it absolutism
he could have said i am sticking
absolutely
firmly to the speed of light and the
constancy of the speed of light
and the rigidity of that as a
fundamental cosmic limit
and by sticking to that absolute
parameter so rigidly
he actually initiated a complete
revolution and how we understand the
cosmos we have the big bang
and black holes in an expanding universe
and all of these things and time travel
and all of these things
that would not have been conceivable had
he not imposed that limit
so i often when i write think very hard
about structure i think very hard about
limits
and you talk about how small this book
is it didn't start small
in a way it started really big my first
lump of material was was three times
bigger
three times as long and uh and it was a
it was a process of
imposing those constraints to figure out
what the book really was and anything
else had to go
yeah i think it was uh descartes or
maybe it was voltaire who said
uh if i had more time i would have made
it shorter
it's mark twain oh mark twain
and i actually i actually just thought
of that quote the
in an interview the other day mark twain
said i didn't have time to write a short
letter so i wrote a long one instead
yes exactly so i always hate it as i
said last time when uh when authors are
on podcast and they say
can you please explain your entire book
uh preferably in the exact same voice
you narrate for the audiobook so that
you know our listeners can save a few
dollars
uh but uh um what is the basic uh thesis
of the book
in that you you took on something that's
incredibly challenging to have art and
science blended together
who is the inner critic because i know
you have an inner critic that uh you
talked about it with tim ferriss and
on his podcast and you have this voice
inside your head
who are you writing to who is your
audience the artist the scientist
some educated you know fool who can't
draw a stick figure like me who is it
yeah
well well i think those are two two
questions and and
i when i was reading popular science
book
when i was very young i did not like the
kind of
condescending tone of some of them as
though here we are the great masters
having climbed to the summit coming down
with a tablet
right and and and declaring our
discoveries
i very much think about the books i
write as books
that i want to read and so to a large
extent and some people will criticize
this
to a large extent i am my most severe
critic and i am also
my most targeted audience and the reason
why i wanted to write this particular
book
is because i wanted to dispel a lot of
myths about black holes
and there are a lot of myths about black
holes like black holes
are dense objects as though you roll up
to the event horizon and you knock on
the surface of this very dense thing
the first chapter which which really
launched kind of conceptually
all the chapters was to insist that
black holes are
nothing to to convey that they are
absolutely empty and that
it's more than that in some sense black
holes are not objects
at all they're they're a place what they
are is they are a place in space time or
you could say we're strongly they
are a space time they are a place
literally they are a space and a time
and um
and that kind of thematic thinking
is a current through the whole book
really dispelling myths about black
holes
i muted myself unintentionally my sound
a sonic black hole which you also talk
about in this book um you're you are
your own engineer
yeah that's right although i am not a uh
a guggenheim genius like you are
at figuring these things out i want to
ask you um
are singularities real i mean if you had
a you know bet your neighbors annoying
you know pet ferret uh that keeps you up
at night yeah in new york city
uh would you bet the existence of that
uh creature's life on the existence and
reality of a singularity it seems like
we kind of have this urberos or whatever
you call it this this self-circular
argument that well singularities are
needed because uh
uh they they provide the realm in which
we notice that gravity
is insufficiently married to quantum
mechanics and then we say oh well
quantum mechanics must be
married to gravity because otherwise we
can't uh we can't
uh work out the physics at the
singularity in a black hole or in the
big bang
but who ordered them i mean why do we
know first of all there's no evidence
for them
uh experimental we can't get them as you
point out in the book
i'm not going to spoil the ending of the
vlog of the black hole survival guide
but um are they real i mean do you
really believe that they exist or are
they just kind of like this tool like
the number infinity which we don't know
if it exists either
right right um so so it's interesting
because a nobel prize this year which
which was awarded to sir roger who you
just had on your show
um sir roger penrose in the 60s the work
he did that earned him the nobel prize
these 50 years later um more than 50
years later
uh was that he proved mathematically
that if you have a collapsing star
it not only leaves an event horizon
behind it
it does become that dense object that
people think is a black hole
but but the star is not the black hole
when it becomes a certain density it
creates around it what we call the event
horizon the region beyond which you
cannot escape not even light can escape
but what roger proved is that it
continues to fall
the star can no more sit there then it
can travel outward the speed of light
it's what it would have to try to do
it's as though space time becomes a
waterfall
and the star is forced to fall more and
more and more and get smaller and
smaller
until it catastrophically forms and and
roger showed that this is what the
predictions are of the mathematics of
general relativity
a singularity and infinite curvature in
space and time
and then he says in this paper therefore
this isn't his exact wording
singularities are probably signaling
the breakdown of the theory of general
relativity
because physically they are anathema and
um and so he also argued that once we
once we understand the quantum behavior
of space-time
which would be probed near the
singularity it will be like a false
prophecy it will go away
and um and so he even says this in this
paper and i believe
that there are very few uh theoretical
physicists
who believe that a singularity exists i
would not
base my ferret's life on it absolutely
it's my favorite oh my neighbor's
favorite
um we have a lot of animals but we don't
have a ferret
um so i i would very much
uh argue that what the singularity does
for us
is it signals to us where we need to
start thinking about quantum mechanics
and quantum gravity
and even how we need to start thinking
about it so
we the resolution of what happens to
that collapsing star
the original story that it falls into a
singularity and gets
who knows what happens to it it falls
out of space time it ceases to exist
it is a terrible thing to make such a
prediction first of all as you said we
don't see infinities in nature
and second of all it means that we've
lost
the ability to have physical reality to
some extent
things simply drop out of existence
and and that seems to be a pretty strong
message
that we've gotten something wrong and it
doesn't mean that the whole of general
relativity is wrong it's absolutely
beautiful it's absolutely
excellently tested it means that at
those scales it's just not complete
interesting so um the other thing that
you got into is the quantum nature
of of black holes and how they've kind
of
um you know really enraptured
physicists ranging from you know
beckenstein and hawking
all the way up to uh you know obviously
with sir roger
and and beyond and of course recently
many many nobel prizes have been awarded
for black holes
uh why why do they fascinate ordinary
individuals i mean to the extent that
someone knows about general relativity
uh in the lay person realm it's uh oh a
black hole or you know
um maybe they might know something about
uh about
uh well i don't even know maybe
something that's associated with the
singularity at the beginning of
our current epoch in the universe um but
why is it that
uh that they know about that uh that
black hole specifically why not
why don't they know about uh you know
gravitational weak lensing or something
different
right well black holes really do have a
cultural aura that is
not usually associated with
astrophysical phenomena
one of the reasons obviously the the
the actual physical phenomena is
fascinating
the warping of the space and time
astrophysically the fact
that they are the death state of very
massive stars is just remarkable when
einstein first heard about black holes
they weren't called that
he gets a letter from a friend with in
which the mathematics is described and
he he
appreciates mathematics he thinks it's
true but but
he doesn't think that nature will allow
them nature will protect us from their
formation
and it was quite extraordinary that
after decades people realized
that nature thought of a way to make
them and it was by killing off a few
stars
so um if you kill off very massive stars
they will collapse under their own
weight they're heavy enough
that no resistance from matter can
stop the catastrophic collapse and
they will form a black hole but the
reason
that it's so interesting on the quantum
side and the modern side
is when we step away from astrophysics
and we say
uh what are black holes telling us about
physics in general
now when a star dies and it makes a
neutron star
or which is a dead star that's not heavy
enough to become a black hole which does
have a surface which is an
object it is made of stuff and you can
go up to it you can knock on it would
not be a good idea it's a very
dense and dangerous place to be but um
but it's not uh the black hole is
different because the black hole
as we said in the beginning in some
sense isn't an object it's a place
it's actually a perfect place there's a
sense in which a black hole is
fundamental to the laws of
nature and that makes it unlike
any other astrophysical phenomena i can
think of
a black hole is almost like a perfect
fundamental particle
not dissimilar from how an electron is a
perfect fundamental particle as far as
we know maybe it's made up of strings or
something else but
but the idea if i have one electron and
i have another electron
they are identical and flawless they
have exactly the same mass
they have exactly the same charge they
have exactly the same
quantum features and they are
technically completely
indistinguishable there is no experiment
you could perform that says ah this
electron is a little fatter
than this one you know but stars aren't
like that a neutron star can be a little
bigger than its neighbor and it might
have a little mountain on it has a tiny
feature
and little distinguishing features black
holes are perfectly flawless
they are featureless and and that makes
them
exceptional as astrophysical objects it
also makes them
a terrain on which we can explore
fundamental physics
and so people who are talking about
hawking radiation and talking about
uh the very wild modern ideas which get
really out there they are using the
black hole
as a frontier to explore and the only
frontier
really of its kind that allows us to
to do those explorations and and to
probe the real quantum nature of gravity
and
and of the laws of physics so that's
very beautiful i want to come back to
the fungibility of black holes
in a bit um and i did say that you know
electrons can't be fatter my electrons
can be fatter and
i've struggled my elementary quarter
my avatar in the particle world is the
crouton um
i want to ask you a question from
another brian uh brian penley
who asked if a black hole would take
longer than the age of the universe to
significantly dissolve
i think what he means is uh is hawking
evaporate
eventually eons and eons from now is
there a chance that the universe too
will evaporate eons and eons from them
well it's a very interesting question
the bigger the black hole
the more slowly it evaporates and um
it it as it gets smaller it will
begin to probe the quantum properties
more strongly and those processes become
more important so the astrophysical
black holes that we see in the universe
are not hawking radiating they're
actually absorbing
way more than they emit so they're
really technically not hawking
evaporating yet
but if i left a black hole alone i took
away
all the background light left over from
the big bang so it couldn't even absorb
that
that heat so there was just in a cold
empty universe
indeed it would begin to evaporate and
as it gets smaller and smaller the
evaporation gets more
catastrophic and accelerated and
eventually it really just explodes
at the end and we believe is gone and
but it does
the part the radiation itself is there
the hawking radiation
exists in the universe and so we could
conceive of a far
future in the cosmos in which the
universe
is simply full of hawking radiation
and and that won't evaporate anymore
we will be left with whatever turns out
to be actually fundamental maybe there
are fundamental
strings maybe they really are particles
these are things that are still under
debate but
it would be as though the universe was
just this smooth
hot bath of the radiation left over
from from these exploding black holes
and in
there is a scenario in which you can
imagine that the universe effectively
dies that way
because we no longer perceive a passage
of time there's no longer
any more change there's there's just the
same
second after second you couldn't under
you couldn't perceive a passage of time
in a universe that
that was just essentially having a kind
of a heat death
ah gives me uh gives me an idea for your
next book so
universe no one here gets out alive
um how to survive the end of the
universe yeah
i actually have a book that i
interviewed uh last week
uh how to die in space by paul sutter
you may know is also a famous
youtuber speaking of youtube i want to
remind folks to click
on the comments and the chat because
janna's back tonight
uh with a uh joining in the great debate
we're commemorating the 100th
anniversary of the great debate the
so-called kurdish shapley debate
we're going to be looking at
supermassive uh black holes at the
center of galaxies
no not with my puny little two-inch
telescope but we're actually going to be
using a massive telescope in wyoming to
do some live star gazing if the weather
cooperates
uh but while you're up there so reach up
uh subscribe
and hit the notification bell and you'll
find out later on tonight
6 p.m uh pacific uh p.m eastern
so getting back to black holes so you
talk a lot about what happens when
material objects go close to a black
hole because as you
note we are made of matter you know
we're basically made of three things
two quarks and an electron mixed
together
i always wondered how can a black hole
be charged i mean we only know of two
charges one's uh you know not elementary
uh
you know we think of electrons as
negatively charged and then the quarks
have you know fractional charges
uh but how do we charge if there's
basically no
thing you keep saying this in the book
black holes are no thing no matter
how can nothingness have charge
yeah you can even start with the
question how can nothingness have mass
yes and it's it's quite it's quite um
a tricky it feels like a sleight of hand
to say there's nothing there
but it has mass if you believe as some
people used to i don't think it's a very
popular idea anymore
that the collapsing star let's say
that's how you made the black hole
forms a quantum remnant in the interior
then it would be
easier to discuss things like well
you're really assigning the mask to the
remnant on the inside or the charge
uh to the or they're charged to the
remnant on the inside but that's really
not
what we're saying we're saying it
doesn't matter if it's a remnant doesn't
matter if there's a real singularity and
stuff of the star is
gone what happens is it has imparted
to the gravitational energy an
equivalent mass
so the black hole has a gravitational
energy from far away
even though it's not an object you would
imagine
there's an object there and it wouldn't
be until you got closer that you would
realize it's nothingness there
but the gravitational field itself has
an equivalent energy
to the mass that went into it and
similarly
the gravitational field can have a
charge when we say
what is the shape of the space time
around a black hole it is different
the gravitational field itself is
different
if there is charge and um and so in that
sense what you're doing is you're
imparting
these characteristics to the space time
itself
and then it's a subtle issue yeah it's
it is and these are
mysterious objects you talk in a lecture
that i really enjoyed at uh brown
university
uh about uh you know magnet magnetic
black holes and batteries and so forth
and all sorts of oh yeah
possible uh possible relevant things so
i want to move now into your research
uh but before we do i want to uh
someone's asking me what do you think
about the
uh the fact that there are um black
holes
thought to be supermassive in size at
the centers
of almost all galaxies why is that i
mean why
the galaxies have a tremendous amount of
dark matter and the dark matter is not
necessarily related to the black holes
and yet we find that they have a
tremendous number
of high correlation between black holes
and
supermassive black holes in galactic
galaxies so why is that
well i would say to some extent we don't
really know
we don't know how they got so super
massive so you might have a scenario
like this
very big stars early in the universe
even bigger than the kinds of stars we
make today
a different population of stars collapse
directly
uh this this these bigger stars are from
an earlier era
out of primordial stuff and they form
bigger black holes and those bigger
black holes collide and merge and that's
in fact what ligo detected we
know that black holes merge and get
bigger
and so maybe over lots of years of of
finding other black holes
they became super massive now some
people argue
that you really can't form them that way
there's not enough time there's not
there aren't enough collisions
and all of this stuff is stuff we're
working out now because we're making
discoveries month by month
ligo detected for the first time
intermediate mass black holes black
holes that aren't tens of times the mass
of the sun
but hundreds and or at least
in the hundred range opening the door to
others that are hundreds of times the
massive sun
and then there were far off these
supermassives so it's possible that
super massive black holes
simply collapsed out of
the primordial stuff skipping stars all
together
and and formed that way now we don't
know which comes first
the galaxy or the black hole and but we
we are starting to understand
that the black hole shapes the galaxy
that it has a lot of responsibility for
the size of the galaxy
for regulating the size of the galaxy
for instance we know that there are
these incredible jets
that are churned up outside the black
hole they don't come from the interior
because nothing comes out of the black
hole but they're churned up
in the environment around the black hole
and that these jets can
can drive particles and winds that
regulate how big a galaxy can get
and if you look at the size of these
supermassive black holes the largest
ones i believe are in the tens of
billions of times the mass of the sun
um yeah so that's pretty big the one in
our galaxy is four million times the
mass of the sun
which is also pretty big um but
even so it makes up a pretty small
fraction of the mass of the whole galaxy
and that's and that's funny so people
thought well maybe they're not that
important to the galaxy but we're
starting to understand
that to some extent where we live on
earth
in the milky way in orbit around a
supermassive black hole
that that that whole history and story
could largely our origins our history
could largely
have been shaped by that black hole and
ultimately that that's where we're going
to end up
i mean that's our fate in a certain
there's a certain scenario in which we
end up
as we orbit that black hole in a very
very far future
eventually falling into the supermassive
black hole yeah
thank you ali wright for that question
uh so
next question that i have is uh someone
wants your opinion
on conformal cyclic cosmology
which features the potential emergence
of so-called hawking points and i talked
a little bit with this about with sir
roger after you
uh graciously attended and then had to
leave on friday that went on for another
nine hours no no it didn't go on that
one
it felt like nine so roger is known for
that yes his conciseness
is not uh it was very surprising to me
that he was so gracious
as are you but i want to know um
and this person wants to know what do
you think of conformal cyclic cosmology
because it really relies on the only
things
making it through to the other side uh
in sort of the doris language would be
would be black holes so i have to say
um i don't know that much about it but i
have re it has recently been on my mind
so so let's just to just to kind of uh
reframe the idea in a very simple way
the idea
is that if in this far future the
universe really is
just a hot bath of particles and
it really becomes just so smooth
that it has no identifiable features in
some sense which
you know obviously right now new york
city has very strongly identifiable
features we're far from that future but
if you imagine just everything
disintegrating
into like a hot bath his idea is that
that is conformal meaning you can map
that
to a different what feels or seems like
a different universe at a different
temperature
and and that you can't really tell the
difference
uh anymore so he i don't fully
understand the arguments
but he he's essentially saying well then
the far
future which looks like the heat death
of the universe might actually be
mappable to the big bang
and that we might have this cyclic
series
of events where we really have
the same conditions as we have in a big
bank and
um i i admit i don't fully understand it
i've tried to talk to other people
about it and they don't fully understand
it and sometimes you know
this is both sir rogers strength and his
um
what what earns him sometimes uh uh
debates is in contention
is is that uh he either sees something
we're not seeing
or he's or he has an intuition that he
hasn't yet
completely secured and and and you know
maybe there will be
a a time where he he seals it up more
and that the rest of us can come along
but i think right now it's a very
challenging
about fascinating idea yeah no i love
his creativity
uh i love the fact that he is uh he's
open to criticism because i said to him
you know i think you're uh you know it's
one of my friends james altitude says
you know
smoking your own crack i mean i didn't
put it to him just like that
it's hard to tell that to someone as
gracious as sir roger
what are the most mysterious mesmerizing
uh from an artist's side because i i
view you you know there's an old joke
what do you call someone who hangs out
with with musicians you call him a
drummer
but if i don't know if you're an artist
i don't know your artistic abilities
uh i know in the verbal arts obviously
you're a genius par excellence but
i don't know you're kind of an honorary
artist you've done so many
collaborations
what's the most mesmerizing aspect of a
black hole i'm showing the final image
from your book you can't see it because
it's on my screen but it's this image
here
of the astronaut um yes uh going into
that with that with the black hole
reflected on her visor
and i just think it's so it's so
beautiful but what is and this this
image that we can finally simulate what
a black hole looks like and
what two black holes colliding together
what fascinates you the most the art of
the black hole or the mysterious science
of the black hole
i i don't um i can't separate them
in some sense we have these we are
driven by emotions there is
allegedly a story of from neuroscience
and i'm going to butcher it terribly
because i'm not a neuroscientist about
somebody who had you know one of those
famous polls through the head stories
yes and and how they change and here
this happened to somebody and he
maintained his intellect to a certain
extent he could do certain puzzles
he could speak he could he could uh was
reasonably mathematical but he could no
longer make a decision
because his emotional centers were
damaged so if he went to dinner like the
chicken or the fish like he couldn't
make a call tried the penguin he should
have had the penguin penguin is like
half chicken that fish trust me
so so i don't think we're as
compartmentalized
as we talk about these days i don't know
that they can be separated
if i get you know literally stirred when
i think about
black holes sometimes when i think about
the mathematics sometimes when i
when i find the right language for it i
get i moved
so um so i don't think i can separate
the artistry
from the intellectual interest and um
and i think if we really really could
we'd probably be like the guy who
couldn't choose the chicken or the fish
and that's something we would we would
not be perceived as integrated whole
um people so uh yeah i mean the idea of
what is i want to mention about this
picture that you showed because i
i think that really speaks to how how
wonderful this collaboration was with
leah
uh we just understood each other there
was not a ton of i don't know what
you're looking for i don't understand
what you need or
really it was just the first drafts of
the paintings were all so close
it was the most smallest changes that we
were talking about at the end
and that image was was uh was one that i
said to her you know i really
i really know what i want at the end i
want an astronaut
with this big black hole reflected in
the visor you know the sense
of of this impending kind of disaster
or but but beautiful right and even like
the tilt of the astronauts body
um and um and the sense of
of being alone in space and confronting
this phenomenon and it's it's not just a
real astronaut going out and doing those
things
or or even a sci-fi astronaut going out
and doing those things it's a metaphor
for
for the exploration as a scientist to
some extent
so uh naveen navnit is asking how does a
magnetic field
oops around a black hole create a
create a charge on a black hole
oh so this is exactly what i researched
this is this is when i'm doing physics
and i'm talking to my graduate students
and my students um
this is what we're very interested in it
is
um quite interesting that a black hole
can act uh effectively like a battery
in a magnetic field and what do you mean
by that so so here's an example from
old-fashioned physics late 1800s
if i have a magnet a big enough magnet
and uh and i wave it around i can create
electricity
and uh this dates back to faraday so if
i took a light bulb right now
disconnected from a lamp not plugged
into any electrical source at all
and i waved the magnet around i could
light
that light bulb up it would create
current
in that light bulb it's absolutely
amazing in the early days of e m were
the first examples of a unified theory
and a
really beautiful aspects of that whole
model
so the black hole is like a waving
magnet when it's in a magnetic field
it's churning the magnetic field up a
scenario that i often work on is a
neutron star
which is a this cloud star we discussed
which has tremendous
magnetic fields sometimes trillions of
times the magnetic field of the earth
and it's orbiting a black hole so now
you have literally the waving magnet
and what the black hole uh creates out
of
this system the black hole by forcing
the neutron star orbit around
is acting in a sense like a battery it's
creating electricity
and so now you have the opportunity for
charges to flow along the magnetic field
lines
and and uh and get absorbed into the
black hole
and it can it has been proven that in
magnetic fields
it's not the case that equal and
opposite charges flow in
which would leave the black hole with
zero charge in the end
but that it preferentially picks uh
one charge over the other and this
depends on the spin of the black hole
which charge it picks and the magnitude
of the charge
but it is energetically favorable it is
the lowest energy state is one way of
thinking about it
if it acquires charge and this is very
interesting because it means that in
these systems black holes themselves
become
charged when they when a charge spins it
creates its own magnetic field
so that the black hole could become like
a really bizarre pulsar
and a pulsar is a neutron star with a
big magnetic field that has
like a lighthouse beam that sweeps
around so you could have these scenarios
where the black hole becomes like a
lighthouse
once it's acquired the charge
interesting
pretty cool yeah no they have all these
sorts of interesting properties and i
i would be remiss if i don't talk about
hawking radiation and
one thing that's always kind of uh
dogged at me
was this notion that black holes
evaporate
and the way that we conventionally tell
our students uh they evaporate
uh uh caused by hawking radiation
is that there are these virtual
particles that pop out of the
very active vacuum uh that aristotle
amongst others
said was aboard by nature uh but in fact
there's vacua all around
but nevertheless um how is it possible
so and you have a beautiful description
which i think
you know follows the conventional
discussion of it um
which is that you know one of the
particles you know two particles
uh enter and one particle leaves and
that always sounded a little bit strange
to me because in one sense the particle
you have energy flowing into a black
hole from one of the virtual particles
the other one's going off to infinity so
yes i could see that you would see it as
light but why would that cause the black
hole to lose mass if it's actually a
quantum
energy yeah well actually in a very
subtle way this
is related to the argument that once
you're on the inside of the black hole
the singularity is always in your future
it is utterly inevitable
that you hit the singularity in the
future if you left your astronaut
companion behind on a space station that
was safely orbiting
they would imagine that the singularity
was at the center
in space of this of this black hole
space
but to you the that direction is time
and that's a really ex that's uh that
you're saying basically that space and
time begin to change for those two
astronauts
more and more dramatically as you reach
the event horizon
to the point where your time appears to
stand still
so much so that when you cross the event
horizon
if they were to conti which they can't
continue to see you but
they would imagine that now your time
has actually pointed fully in the
spatial direction as though you've
rotated time completely
so for you the interior of the black
hole is directed in the future now why
is this relevant to the hawking
conversation and this is the hard stuff
it's relevant because when i create two
particles
outside the black hole quantum
fluctuating out of the vacuum
you would imagine that they both have to
have positive energy because we only
know of things that have positive energy
however if one of them is slightly
interior
to the event horizon and one of them is
slightly outside which is permitted in
the quantum spread of not knowing
exactly where things are and the
uncertainty principle
the one on the interior can have
negative energy it's not energy to them
to them
it has to do with a negative uh motion
through space
but from the balance of the outside in
the same sense that space and time have
switched places
energy and momentum have switched places
from the outside they would say
that's a negative energy that was just
absorbed but
inside the black hole it's it's not a
negative energy because this isn't
energy is your has to do with your flow
through time and this isn't the time
direction anymore
so it doesn't violate any laws or
physics it's
the person inside still perceives a
positive energy because they say that's
not the time direction anymore
and so it actually from the outside
you would measurably say it has absorbed
negative energy
which is e equals m c squared energy and
that energy is going to reduce the mass
of the black hole
it's a very subtle process yes it's
extraordinary
another uh excellent question from ollie
wright again
uh and ollie's asking how can something
so smooth
and some symmetrical so unlike you
hair free as well as wheeler does it
how does something so smooth and
symmetrical have such high entropy
oh it's a it's a really important
question
um so it is it is
very important question there are
entropies
that have to do with
uh disorder but there are also
entropies which have to do with a lack
of knowledge they're not unrelated
because when we think of disorder
let's just think about regular entropy
when i take a bunch of
coins and they're all stacked perfectly
and that looks like a very ordered
low entropy state because it's so
incredibly ordered there's many fewer
ways to stack it
so perfectly that when i take them and i
throw them on the floor and they're in a
random
arrangement but that has to do
technically with my lack of knowledge
of that micro state it's they can't
they're all different states every time
i throw them to the ground
right different directions different
orders it never lands exactly the same
way
it's that i can't really tell the
difference between those anymore
so it does have to do with my lack of
information
my inability to to distinguish
so i call that a high entropy state now
what's happening with the event horizon
is it is imposing a fundamental lack of
information
about what's on the interior and and
that corresponds to a kind of an entropy
and again it's a subtle argument it
means that there are all kinds of ways
that i could have made a black hole
let's just say the simplest one it only
has mass
no charge in a spin there are all kinds
of ways i could have made that black
hole
i could have made it with encyclopedia
britannica as i could have made it
with a collapsing star i could have made
it in the universe and so
through some phase transition and there
are it could have been made
fundamentally in a collider
what i will never know from the outside
had i not witnessed its formation is the
difference between those states
i can't because the event horizon
forbids my
my ability to extract that information
it hides all of that information and as
a result
we know that's what we really ultimately
mean by entropy
so it corresponds fundamentally to a
lack of knowledge
of the exact state on the interior and
the variety of arrangements of the state
of the interior
and i can't resist because i talked a
little bit about that with roger penrose
white holes and you mentioned them kind
of in passing
because it's not the white hole survival
guide after all it's the black ones
um but he has a cartoon that i showed
the other day
which is called a hypothetical white
hole which is the time reverse of a
black hole
such as depicted and figured and you
were the first person to really convince
me to believe
that time and space interchange their
their orientation
their manifestation so first of all how
can you have a reversal of time
in a white hole without creating you
know just the opposite like the
a double negative now space that was
time is now time that was space so
how is that possible well it's really
um it's it's here's what i would say
about the white holes just to just to
start
there's there's no prediction that we
have
that interior to a black hole you
predict a white hole but
what we do know is that i can smoothly
sew those space times together
and and that's kind of cool right so
so it if you tried to sew the interior
space time
of a black hole onto i don't know some
some other space time
it wouldn't fit together it wouldn't
work you would have it would be like
sewing
a hyperbolic sheet of paper to a flat
sheet of paper you would have lumps and
it just wouldn't be smooth
but but the white hole and the black
hole actually are smoothly sewn
you can technically mathematically sew
them together now that's not a
prediction
but it's really cool so some people
thought oh
maybe when you fall into the black hole
the singularity goes into a white hole
singularity and you match onto a big
bang
i think that those questions about space
and time
as we've been describing are
fundamentally relative it
absolutely depends on whom you ask and
so
the person for instance falling inside
the black hole does not see time stop
on the event horizon they're not
confused about the direction of time
it's a perfectly smooth transition for
them and they believe the singularity is
in the future and then similarly
they will their coordinate frame that
they're bringing with them their rulers
and their clocks if they could survive
this journey
would allow you to smoothly transition
through their time coordinate
it's only from the outside the people
who are not taking the journey
that it looks so strange and
so um so it's really it's really an
extreme version of the relativity of
space and time
that it depends on whom you ask and
um uh and
so so the interesting thing then though
just the white one thing about white
holes that i love to think about
is that it's as though the black hole
however big
it is on the outside let's say our sun
were to become a black hole and it was
only six kilometers across
that's how small it would be i love
reminding people that black holes are
heavy but they're small
i mean they're tiny that's the whole
point of the block half of manhattan
that yeah i could stick it in central
park
so uh so now you have this tiny uh
this this tiny event horizon what do we
mean by the size of the black hole we
mean the shadow cast by the event
horizon
and within that tiny region you could
have
what we're discussing is an entire
universe on the inside
and so black holes are the ultimate of
doctor who's tardis
right they're bigger on the inside than
they are on the outside
oh very good yeah so i know we're coming
to the end here
i know you've got a um uh you're going
to have a book event tonight
with harvard oh yes book cop yeah you
want to say something about
that and then i've got a couple of
questions i want to close with
yeah thanks for thanks for reminding me
sir i have a book event
online tonight with the harvard
bookstore i really hope people will tune
in
it's at 7 00 p.m we have to support our
local bookstores
it's heartbreaking to know that harvard
bookstore which is an absolute tradition
in cambridge
you know i went to mit and took a lot of
classes at harvard
and the harvard bookstore is a deeply
charming wonderful bookstore they do a
lot of events they support a lot of
authors and we have to support
bookstores now so i really hope people
will tune in
um to that talk and i'll be able to show
a lot of the visuals a lot of the
paintings from the book
and so um so i hope people will enjoy
that
and that's 7 p.m and you can just look
up on my twitter account
i'm putting out channel 11. i'll put it
on the uh
i'm putting in the links right now yeah
here we go okay link to it
yeah yeah that's uh not to be missed uh
it'll be virtual
i assume yeah
see if we can get a better a better draw
on the into the impossible podcast
uh i want to close there are a few more
questions but i know you have to run
you've been so generous with your time
uh if you had to go to a black i have to
go prepare my talk i know i know
oh yeah that's right that's the one
benefit with me you don't have to
prepare anything i'll take whatever i
can
right i love this yeah and then tonight
you've got uh
you don't have to do any preparation
tonight by the way tonight's above yeah
i mean i trust
they'll they'll carry the heavy history
side i'll just talk about the black also
exactly yeah we'll have another chance
of janna tonight
um i want to ask you you know if you had
the chance uh i'm not going to give away
the end of the book at all because i
love the book and it's so suspenseful
uh but if you had a chance would you
take a ride to a black hole
this is a form of a question that i ask
people on occasion if you had a
um if you had a 15 chance of surviving
and going to the sagittarius a star that
you wax so poetically and so beautifully
about in the book
um would you take that chance of
surviving such an encounter
under your own guidance
well here's here's the trick about
sagittarius a star so it's 26
000 light years away so that means if we
could conquer the technology and the
the energy budget that would basically
cost all the energy resources in the
universe
to accelerate a spacecraft to near light
speed
you can arrive at sagittarius a star
still vigorous with youth
uh although 26 000 years would have
passed on earth
and that would be inevitable and um so
you you wouldn't be so worried about the
the election you know civilizations
would have come and gone
um but uh but you could arrive there
vigorous with youth
and and explore the black hole now would
i
really do it um i used to want to go to
space there were crazy things i
used to want to do but then you know i
became attached to my family and my
children
and to the experience of life you can
bring them along but they also have a 15
chance of well you wouldn't have you
know you wouldn't have to keep office
hours so that would be a benefit
but i'll tell you there is one really
cool
uh hitch of hope for your survival and
it's completely absurd but it's fun to
mention it
suppose you fall into that black hole
suppose
your quantum bits are flayed and you are
torn to your fundamental particles
but suppose hawking radiation figures
out a way
to get that information outside from
inside the black hole
this is what the whole debate is about
the event horizon doesn't let anything
out
but you can't lose information so what
happened to the information
but if hawking radiation allows you to
do that and
my astronaut companion faithfully
collected
all of the hawking radiation and decoded
in the fire what happened to me
technically it's conceivable i could be
reassembled
something to look forward to in the deep
well jenna i want to uh thank you for
being so generous with your time as
always i want to remind people to tune
in thank you brian subscribe to the
arthur c clarke center for human
imaginations podcast on itunes this will
be posted there
uh use your finger get some exercise
been it's been lazy
click subscribe click the notification
bell so you'll know when janna comes
back tonight
uh i put the link up to your harvard
talk uh janet congratulations
it's just it's just so phenomenal you
give you're such an inspiration
to people like me who struggle uh to do
uh what you do so
so effortlessly that's all i can say
it's it's really i really appreciate you
it's like the duck paddling underneath
the water
or the water
well you do it with such ease and
graciousness yeah that's all we can
assume
thank you so much thank you for this
podcast it's a really special podcast
i'm so glad you're doing it
i love doing it yeah we encourage people
to keep tuning in
okay jenna thank you so much off to your
event and i'll just conclude with a
couple of words to my audience here that
i had a wonderful time with janna she'll
be back again tonight so please do
subscribe leave a comment
and make sure that you register we have
some giveaways including janna's book
which will come from our local bookstore
warwick's
bookstore here in la jolla and we are
supporting local
as well and that will be uh sent to one
lucky winner we also have a copy of
sarah sieger's wonderful book the
smallest lights in the universe that'll
be given away
and uh and finally we have two copies
well we have a book called losing the
nobel prize
uh for those of you who want uh such a
such a piece of direct compared to
the other works of art uh but then we
also will have uh papers given away
signed papers by adam maurice
and by wendy friedman so janna will be
there if that's not a draw enough to
come back please do i'll put the link
to register for the giveaway on the
screen janna go take care of that ferret
that ferret's making too much noise
you're like noam chomsky he had his dog
barking the whole time no
no he's barking thank you all so much
have a wonderful day join us tonight do
not forget
join us tonight i'm putting up on the
broadcast where you can find
the link to register to win janna's book
straight from
the center of a black hole for now
signing off brian keating and jenna
levin
bye bye
you